j'accueille notre invité bruno
retailleau bonsoir merci vous êtes
président aujourd'hui du groupe l'est
républicain au sénat mais vous avez
aussi été président du conseil général
et vous aviez sous votre responsabilité
2500 pompiers donc vous comprenez bien
la situation sur les caractères la
plupart étaient des volontaires et
j'avais 250 professionnels en même temps
donc comment est-ce que vous réagissiez
ce qui s'est passé cet après midi ce
soir d'abord peut-être sur les tensions
mais aussi sur les revendications
d'abord sur les revendications ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que des
sapeurs pompiers en ont ras-le-bol parce
qu'ils sont la voie de recours de tout
ce qui ne marche pas il ya plus de
médecins des médecins de ville en
campagne est maintenant dans certains
quartiers et donc on les appelle les
urgences sont encombrées et donc souvent
on les appelle le 15 régule pas toujours
ensuite on a des soucis
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et on a des
soucis parce que les sapeurs pompiers
dans mon département
j'ai appris que il y avait près d'une
dizaine de sapeurs pompiers qui s'était
fait agresser dans l'année alors que
c'est un département plutôt rural donc
il concentre vraiment beaucoup de
difficultés la société française il faut
les écouter mais on ne peut pas régler
uniquement le problème des pompiers sont
réglés aussi le problème de la
désertification médicale
le problème des urgences c'est ce qui
rend la question très très difficile moi
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas du tout
bénéficié d'une bonne écoute du
ministère de l'intérieur
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé est ce
qu'il ya eu un printemps de malentendus
en tout cas ils ont eu le sentiment
d'être poussée à bout et simplement de
ne pas être écoutés il faut les écouter
leur parler droit dans les yeux
dire que tout ne peut pas être réglé
mais est ce qu'on peut supporter les
violences qu'on fait aujourd'hui dans
certains quartiers ou dans certaines
zones rurales aux sapeurs pompiers c'est
plus possible
chaque jour qui passe vous avez cent dix
policiers gendarmes ou sapeurs-pompiers
qui sont agressés on est devenus une
société de la violence etc les
affrontements aujourd'hui on le voit
qu'ils sont vous quand vous condamnez
enfin cette tension de fin de
manifestation bien sûr sûr que je la
condamne ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
qu'on a là deux services publics
avec les crs services publics la
sécurité et avec les sapeurs pompiers le
service public de la sécurité civile
avec un affrontement nous sommes dans
une société de l'affrontement est
malheureusement en france aujourd'hui
trop souvent ceux qui veulent défendre
des revendications pense que seule la
violence est une voie de recours
elle savait j'ai vécu notre dame des
landes j'avais dit à mes mails macron
qui avait cédé à la violence et à dist
aujourd'hui vous donner raison aux
analystes contre les décisions de
justice contre le référendum
eh bien vous montrer un très mauvais
signal ce soir donc maintenant la
manifestation est dispersée ça s'est
fini dans le calme la circulation a
repris place de la nation comme nous l'a
expliqué notre reporter sur place on va
voter les autres questions qui sont
évidemment aussi importante la question
de la laïcité du port du voile dans
l'espace public était aucun des
questions du gouvernement cet après midi
à l'assemblée nationale vous sénateur de
vendée vous êtes pour une loi qui
interdise le port du voile à des parents
accompagnant les sorties scolaires ce
qui était un peu le débat des ces
derniers jours mais je vous propose
d'écouter edouard philippe
il a répondu à l'assemblée nationale à
cette question et veut ainsi clore ce
débat écoutez je ne pense pas pour ma
part monsieur le député que l'enjeu
aujourd'hui ce soit de faire une loi sur
les accompagnants scolaires
l'enjeu et je pense que nous pouvons
nous retrouver là dessus c'est de
combattre et fita efficacement et avec
le soutien de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
les dérives communautaires maligne en la
matière c'est de mener sans faiblesse la
lutte contre la radicalisation
cette radicalisation islamiste qui
menace notre société voilà la
radicalisation oui il faut s'y attaquer
une loi de plus pour brimer peut-être
des mères accompagnant leurs enfants
sorties scolaires ça n'est pas
nécessaire il s'agit de brimer personnes
quand j'entends le premier ministre dire
que ils voient bien la radicalisation
qui se déploie sur le territoire
français mais que fait-il
très concrètement pour lutter contre on
voit aussi dans notre société il ya un
phénomène il ya un islam radical
politique
oui mais qu'il veut
sa marque d'accord dans nos territoires
bien sûr je vais en parler dans un 100 m
haies ce que est ce qu'il passe par
saint pierre de sa compagne hante
écoutez il s'agit de signes ne voit lui
sa vie parce que c'est très bien car des
bleus sort il faut être très précis car
je réponds premier ministre une fois de
plus par une forme d'hypocrisie
politicienne vous vous défausser sur les
directeurs d'école il a fallu souvenez
vous vous en souviendrez certainement
c'était en 1989 dans un collège de creil
des jeunes collégiennes voilée et il a
fallu quinze ans pour que avec jacques
chirac soit votée la loi interdisant à
des élèves car de porter le voile
pourquoi tout simplement parce que
l'école l'école plus qu'aucun autre
service public doit être protégé
notamment des influences religieuses ou
politiques mais là on est d'accord
monsieur le sénat les parents la mère
qui porte un volet qui accompagnent ces
enfants bien est ce qu'elle est dans les
ciels et à l'extérieur de l'école est ce
que vous considérez qu'elle est un
danger radical islamiste soyons clairs
je pense que l'école c'est en classe et
l'école il y à l'école aussi
hors les murs cet été personne s'en est
aperçu la cour administrative d'appel de
lyon après une décision très importante
pour donner raison un directeur d'école
qui exigeaient à des parents d'élèves en
classe de se soumettre et de ne pas
porter d'un signe visible ostentatoire
d'une religion ou de la politique
et bien pour moi la sortie scolaire fait
partie du temps scolaire c'est une
classe hors les murs et il faut que
notre république se défendent et puisse
imposer une neutralité et sans doute que
ce service public particulier qu'est
l'école doit avoir une exigence réhaussé
en matière de neutralité et de laïcité
c'est d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs
l'exemple de la loi de 2004 puisque dans
les services publics ceux qui sont
astreints au principe de laïcité
neutralité c'est les agents les
fonctionnaires mais jamais les usagers
c'est vous demain vous allez à la poste
vous pouvez venir avec un full islamique
si vous le souhaitez sauf que là avec la
loi 2004 ont dit non il n'y a pas
seulement les professeurs il ya aussi
les usagers du service public c'est à
dire les élèves parce que comme disait
jean
d'ailleurs ça on a des questions sur les
dalles on a des consciences en formation
hier on a des consciences en formation
est un signe ostensible je crois moi que
par ailleurs le voile islamique n'est
pas un bout de tissu quelconque je pense
que c'est un signe je pense que un
certain islam politique l'utilisent pour
marquer une partie de la société
c'est d'ailleurs une visée à la fois
séparatistes sexistes aussi alors on a
lutté pour que la femme soit l'égal de
l'homme
on sait très bien que par 7 voix aussi
il s'agit de dire que souvent la femme
et d'un rang inférieur à l'homme qu'est
ce qu'on veut faire aujourd'hui est ce
que on veut une république debout est-ce
qu on tient nos principes et nos valeurs
ou pas le premier ministre je vais vous
dire le premier ministre se défausse
totalement c'est un manque de courage
total et ça ne m'étonne pas du tout
parce que regarder ce qui s'est passé la
préfecture de paris
on est dix jours après quelles sont les
décisions qui ont été prises depuis est
ce que est ce que justement
dix jours après cette attaque qui fait
qu'il ya une très grande nervosité et
c'est normal et une grande inquiétude et
c'est légitime qui pose des questions
par ailleurs il ya la situation va en
parler en syrie avec les kurdes
attaqué par par les turcs mais pour
autant est ce qu'on peut faire de la
surenchère sur ces questions ou est-ce
qu'on doit être dans le rationnel pas ce
que vous dites il faut interdire
il faut interdire on est dans
l'opposition c'est facile quand j'étais
d'ailleurs comment on fait les arguments
que j'utilise sont tout sauf irrationnel
je vous ai cités un arrêt qui cour
d'appel administratif de lyon
je vous ai indiqué le raisonnement que
j'ai qui fait que l'école doit préserver
doit être un sanctuaire qui préserve les
élèves de toutes les influences
prosélyte extérieur religieuse ou
politique et que on ne doit pas
supporter les signes ostentatoires je
vous ai dit par ailleurs que pour moi le
temps de sorties scolaires c'est le
projet le prolongement de la classe
c'est une école hors les murs voyez que
je ne m'énerve pas c'est avec beaucoup
de calme je le fais aussi je vais vous
dire parce que on a des compatriotes de
confession musulmane qui sont
profondément français
et qui ne sont pas dans une dérive
frérot salafistes c'est aussi à eux
qu'on le doit
voilà pour les aider aussi à faire
respecter un islam qui soit éclairé et
qui ne soit pas dans une dérive côté on
a des livres qui paraissent pratiquement
maintenant tous les mois de certaines de
vos collègues qui ont étudié deux
trappes et bien d'autres choses tout est
là tout est documenté
regardez l'ifop quelqu'un qui a écrit
l'archipel français bien sûr jérôme et
requêtes fauquet qui indiquait que 27 %
de nos compatriotes qui professent cette
confession musulmane pour 27 % d'entre
eux la charia est au dessus de la loi de
la république
donc on a des indicateurs et voyez le
premier ministre répond il répond pour
dire écoutez c'est pas le problème on
s'en occupe pas moi je considère qu' un
terreau qui demain peut fabriquer des
jedi à lens devant nous attaquer à la
fois au terrorisme mais aussi un terreau
qui encourage des dérives qui n'ont rien
à voir avec nos valeurs républicaines
que fait-on face à la turquie qui a
lancé son offensive terrestre vous allez
participer ce soir à un meeting de
soutien aux kurdes avec un stand de
personnalités non bernard henri lévy
jean christophe lagarde ou encore
caroline fourest et vous allez apporter
votre soutien mais concrètement si vous
étiez au gouvernement qu'est ce que vous
feriez est-ce que l'armée française est
ce que l'europe est en capacité de faire
quelque chose bien sûr bien sûr et
malheureusement on baisse les bras elle
l'a aussi moi j'étais des tout premiers
parlementaires à me rendre dans le
kurdistan irakien à erbil c'était en
août 2014 alors qu'il y avait tout cet
exode notamment des yézidie des
chrétiens de la plaine de ninive et j'ai
vu à ce moment là les kurdes leur donner
l'asile
j'ai vu ensuite les kurdes à coban et
lutter j'ai vu c'est grâce on a repris à
4 grâce aux kurdes je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs choses à faire la première
chose il faut qu' on puisse rappeler
l'ambassadeur de france à ankara pour
marquer très clairement de
désapprobation deuxième chose comment se
fait-il que l'europe continue des
pourparlers pour l'adhésion de la
turquie
non c'est fini et puis il faut bien
entendu sur le plan international
obtenir une zone d'exclusion aérienne
c'est important
et y compris en venir sur des solutions
économiques vis-à-vis de la turquie son
économie se porte pas bien
je pense enfin et pour moi c'est le
principal
je pense que dans ces dernières années
la france a commis sur le plan
diplomatique une énorme erreur
nous sommes totalement aligné sur la
politique américaine que ce soit avec
monsieur obama et plus encore avec
monsieur trompe on voit bien que nos
intérêts désormais divergent
il faut donc que l'offre la france
reprenne une attitude diplomatique
conforme à son histoire
sony soir gaullienne d'indépendance
parce que c'est comme cela que en
parlant à la russie bien sûr cet
américain qui commence à être ferme
c'est tout juste et jean tout ramassé un
jauzion la république
effectivement il ya un petit virage il
faudra attendre un peu pour savoir si
c'est uniquement dans les mots ou dans
les actes mais la france doit être cette
puissance d' équilibre qui dans le monde
diallo est capable de dialoguer avec
tous pour la paix dernière question
puisque le temps nous pressent le
aujourd'hui ce soir il ya eu le vote de
la loi de bioéthique à l'assemblée
nationale en première lecture donc elle
ira au sénat
chez vous apparemment 104 un quart des
104 députés ne devait pas voté contre
des députés
les républicains je veux dire ne vais
pas voter contre cette loi et même 10 et
15 à 15 députés devaient voter même pour
cette loi on a le sentiment que à une
certaine droite n'a pas trouvé d'écho
contre ces lois
vous vous êtes en vous en êtes un des
représentant es ce que vous n'êtes pas
déçu par là une forme de faible
mobilisation c'est toi elle et elle est
passée elle passe n'ont cessé des
questions qui sont graves parce que il
ya des désirs d'enfant il ya aussi des
souffrances et et je comprends que ça
mais politiquement c'est difficile de
porter un certain nombre de convictions
moi quand j'ai une conviction je la
porte
quel que soit le bien qu'elle me fasse
ou non sur le plan populaire
moi je cours je pense qu'en tout cas
pour la pma sans père la grande question
c'est que si on estime qu'un enfant n'a
pas besoin de perdre et qu'on me le
prouve
tant qu'on ne leur a pas définitivement
prouvé je pense que le principe de
prudence de précaution doit être à
l'oeuvre
donc j'essaierai de porter cette voie là
dans le débat je pense par ailleurs que
évidemment on l'a bien vu
c'est une marche sur la gpa puisque
désormais vous on légalise en france
comme vous le savez sans doute les
conséquences d'une gpa à l'étranger donc
je pense qu'il faudra là aussi dans ce
texte remettre un certain nombre de
verrous pour sortir de cette hypocrisie
on peut parcours chez des couples
d'hommes français a loué des ventres de
femmes à l'étranger alors que c'est
interdit en france
voilà et puis il ya des il ya d'autres
notamment sur l'embryon notamment sur
les embryons chimères vous savez ce qu
ont fait les japonais en prenant un
embryon animal en lui plantant des
cellules totipotentes humaine
c'est terrible ça parce que là ils nous
ont expliqué qu'ils avaient prévues dans
6 ici c'est dans la loi le lin vert
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas prendre une
chimère avec un embryon humain pour lui
implanter des cellules animales mail
inverse et était possible le conseil
d'état d'ailleurs avait indiqué qu'il
faudrait sans doute faire mais cette
possibilité je n'ai pas encore lu
totalement le texte mais on voit je
donne cet exemple pour dire que il ya
certes la pma son père met en jeu et il
faut pas que la loi disparaissent
uniquement derrière cet aspect sociétale
dernière question le chez les
républicains christian jacob a été élu
président il a dit qu'il ne serait pas
candidat en 2022 il souhaite pas la
tenue de primaires
vous vous aimeriez bien qu'ils aient des
primaires chez les républicains
je pense pareil on pourrait être
candidat je pense que si on pouvait se
passer de primaires ce serait beaucoup
mieux
j'ai toujours indiqué que les primaires
c'est sans doute le plus mauvais
systèmes à l'exception de tous les
autres simplement faudrait qu'on
m'explique que comment fait-on pour
qu'on n'aille pas au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle avec des gens
qui sont à l'extérieur de l'air série
bertrand valérie pécresse
comment fait-on pour pas s'auto éliminer
les uns les autres
donc je crois qu'il va falloir se mettre
autour d'une table discuter et d'essayer
de prévoir une règle qui puisse
départager les uns et les autres parce
que sinon nous serons un certain nombre
qui pourrait se présenter au premier
tour de la présidentielle et alors la
sphère seriez parmi eux
je crois qu'on est on est dans une forme
on est dans une forme si peu attractive
pour les français qu'aucun d'entre nous
peut penser arriver un deuxième tour et
gagner donc je crois qu'il ya un travail
sur les idées sur les propositions va
bien vite et vous souvenez lorsque j'y
allais pour essayer de s'alimenter et de
la politique bon il faut christian
puisse rassembler mais il faut aussi
travailler au fond pour que l'on dise
aux français sur plein de choses ou
emmanuel macron est en train d'échouer
sur la sécurité sur la question
benoît tailleu pardonnez-moi mais
peut-être vous pourrez vous aider à
comprendre a tout simplement dit moi ce
qui a pris françois fillon la semaine
dernière lorsqu'il s'est exprimé et qui
nous a expliqué que macro et r petit
joueur je cite et que lui il avait fait
sortir beaucoup plus de monde dans la
rue sur sa réforme des retraites et que
les gilet jaune s'était pas grand chose
c'est pas exactement
non je n'ai pas eu depuis donc je ne
peux pas répondre simplement ce qu'il a
essayé de dire c'est comme ça que je les
lui c'est que la république était
ébranlé avec les jets les jaunes il
avait connu des désordres beaucoup plus
important et cette faiblesse de la
république ça l'interrogeait mais ça
doit tous nous interroger quand on voit
les affrontements de ce soir quand on
voit ces dernières semaines regarder
tous les grands services publics de
l'état
les gendarmes la semaine dernière les
sapeurs pompiers les urgences l'école
les grands services publics sont en
grève il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas
il ya quelque chose qui est en train de
fracturer la république
et s'il ya aujourd'hui en france des
affrontements ce sont des symptômes
il faut s'en méfier merci beaucoup
d'être venu sur notre plateau bruno
retailleau merci face à duhamel c'est
tout tu t'en reparle de la turquie
justement à tous
[Musique]